ladies and gentlemen the cast of the
office John Krasinski is here to make
your office reunion dreams come true
I just got ordained as a minister or you
guys on Sunday's episode of John's hit
web series some good news the actor
chatted it up with Susan and John two
lovebirds whose proposal was like
something out of a TV show hmm well it
actually was inspired by a TV show
John's TV show The Office to be exact
yeah John pop the question to Susan
right outside of a gas station
convenience store exactly like John's
character Jim pop the question to Pam on
the hit sitcom so I knew the proposal
needed to be something really special
but also really something unique and you
know the offices has been something that
has connected the two of us for a very
very long time so it just felt felt
right that is awesome and then he got
down on one knee and he was like you
know just like Jim I can't wait any
longer
yeah come on now cute right well it gets
even cuter you know in your tweet you
had asked if I would attend the truth is
I am able to attend but only if we do it
right now you think I'm kidding but I
just got ordained as a minister or you
guys without telling John and Susan the
Jack Ryan star got in touch with their
parents and their best friends and
brought them all together in a group
video chat for an impromptu wedding and
he had a special surprise guest Pam well
Jenna Fischer who played Pam on the NBC
show it's your wedding day your wedding
colors are but I went with Indian Way
and that wasn't the last surprise not
even close
ladies and gentlemen the cast of The
Office after the newlywed shared their
first kiss as husband and wife
pretty much the entire cast of the
office joined in on the video chat
kicking off a massive virtual dance
party
yep that's Steve Carell Rainn Wilson BJ
Novak Ed Helms Mindy Kaling Ellie Kemper
Kate Flannery Oscar Nunez Angela Kinsey
Phyllis Smith creed bratton and Brian
Baumgartner
[Music]
who else has full-body chills and wishes
this was their wedding John and Susan
congratulations
epic right well don't expect John to
throw any more weddings on SGN and that
will do it for this episode of sgn but
for the first and only SG and wedding
because let's be honest how does it get
better than that
it doesn't yeah like it really doesn't
back in march steve carell joined john
on some good news to talk about their
hit shows milestone 15th anniversary and
john kinda sorta teased that a little
reunion could happen listen I know
everybody's talking about a reunion
hopefully one day we just get to reunite
as people and just all get to say hi I
mean just to see your face is so great I
miss you a ton man of course over the
years et has talked to members of the
cast about the possibility of a reunion
and honestly it wasn't looking good I
kind of don't want to do it because I
love the show so much I think people
would be disappointed I really do I
don't know what form it would take or
anything I'm sort of agnostic I love
whatever has anything to do with that
show but it's all very hypothetical
right now I have some news about the
office guess what you guys it's not
coming back I have not seen the script
I've written three but no one's accepted
them yet yes in my mind I've written in
my mind and while this virtual reunion
isn't a full-fledged proper reunion I
think it's safe to say we're all here
for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]